hello everyone and welcome to a truly
remarkable game from the final round of
the us championship 2021 uh it's fabiano
corona versus sam shankland and this
game uh is is extremely complicated uh
you're gonna enjoy it there's so much
happening and there is one really
awesome positive video moment so let's
dive straight into it at some point of
the game uh the other two uh games that
uh could decide the first place the one
uh wesley was playing in the one samuel
savion was playing ended in a draw so
that meant uh if fabi wins this game uh
he is the us champion of 2021 uh but
let's see uh how how the game went so
here we have d4 by fabi knight to f6 and
knight to f3 uh going for pretty much
anything uh we have d5 by uh shankland
and now c4 uh we have e6 and now g3
preparing bishop to g2 to go for some
sort of a closed catalan bishop to e7
and now bishop to g2 we have castles by
both players and now d captures on c4
and we have the classic line of the
catalan uh where fabi continues with
queen to c2 he's ready to pick up his
pawn so a6 and now although you could
capture right away
on c4 fabi first place a4 this move is
still
uh the most uh common move in the
position just preventing b5 so bishop to
d7 now preparing bishop the c61 to
counter white's very strong bishop on g2
and now only now we recapture on c4 so
queen captures on c4 and bishop to c6 uh
we have bishop to g5 fabi continues the
development and not knight b to d7 also
very popular is just bishop d5 here
chasing away the queen your bishop is on
a beautiful central d5 square
and you can also start moving your your
c pawn right away so it's a it's a
matter of preference so knight b37 and
rook to d1 now uh we have h6 chasing
back this bishop and now you could bring
the bishop back but then you allow black
really a lot of black and go here black
and gold here this knight can go here
you can shift the knight to h7 and then
go to g5 so uh here it's better just to
capture we have bishop captures on f6
knight captures on f6 and now there is a
game where knight to c3 was played but
here we have knight b to d2 by fabi and
it is now only as of move 13 that we
have a completely new game uh so let's
see how shankland continues uh he plays
a5 and of course why wouldn't he he
wants to prevent white from playing b4
uh and this would be
an an excellent expansion if white did
that uh if you guys are wondering
instead of knight b to d2 white why
didn't white go just b for right away it
seems like a possibility it's really not
because bishop captures on a4 just wins
the pawn if you capture the bishop b5
and then you're in
some real real trouble so like we said
knight beat to d2 a completely new game
we have a5 now stopping b4 and the queen
to d3 now uh you will need uh additional
support for executing e4 so bishop to b
for now this bishop will be a monster
here uh there's no real way to get rid
of it and now e4x5 we have queen to e7
connecting rooks uh and now knight to e5
putting some pressure on uh shanklin's
light square bishop and bishop to d7 and
now fabi could eliminate this bishop
yeah for example you play knight
captures on these seven knight captures
and now you might even play a move like
e5 opening up this um
uh diagonal but it doesn't really do all
that much it's very easy for black to
equalize this just captures capture c6
and nothing is really happening if
anything you have a wonderful d5 square
available for your knight so not much
for white to look forward to here and
you don't want to trade too much because
you really need a win here maybe it was
around this point that the the games
that wesley and savion were playing in
the dinner draw and fabi knew that if he
wins this he wins the championship so
here knight to beat the c4 uh just
improving the position putting on some
pressure uh and now rook after d8 so
this rook has not been developed and now
shanklin will play bishop to e8 uh he
didn't want to play it before to
trap his rook in on on f8 so queen to e3
getting the queen away from the uh from
the d file and only now bishop to e8 and
now uh h4 of course we want to grab more
space uh as that's what um you have to
do in 2021 when you play chess so knight
to d7 going for some traits here and
here fabi goes for it knight captures
bishop captures and only now e5 opening
up this diagonal putting pressure on
this b7 pawn so here we have rook a to
b8 here c6 isn't all that impressive
because you create so many weaknesses
here for the for the white knight to
exploit uh so
maybe not the the greatest way to play
this and also you take away the c6
square from your own bishop and you
really want to play bishop to c6 to
counter this bishop uh because you know
this bishop once it gets that the e4 is
just going to be a monster controlling
the entire board so instead after e5 we
have rook 8 to b8 just guarding the pawn
and now bishop to e4 we have bishop to
e8 and now
queen to f3 i think maybe it was around
this point that the other games ended in
a draw but still i'm not sure if you
guys are wondering why not just
something like bishop to c2 we play
queen e4 and we checkmate the black king
uh well it doesn't really work that way
because now you've taken your bishop off
of this diagonal so black can assume it
with his bishop and after queen to d3
going for some checkmating ideas uh g6
this stops at es you have h5 but queen
to g5 and now you're the one
who who's getting uh sort of checkmated
if h captures on g6 we can just play
queen h5 and how are you defending
against this so you have to be careful
even this we just play king f8 we don't
care queen h1 i mean it's very very ugly
for white
but you know you always have to consider
such things if you can checkmate your
opponent you should do it so here queen
to f3 putting more pressure on b7 uh and
now comes uh well you might expect a
move like c6 this really removes the
threat of bishop captures on b7 but it
also prevents this bishop from coming to
c6 ever pretty much so instead we have
f5 and it's a really really cool move
from uh shankland really a nice one
because now if bishop captures on b7 he
has c5 that's the good stuff now the
bishop is attacked twice you have to
move it and after the bishop moves so
let's say we capture captures captures
and now c captures on d4 and it's
shanklin who has a wonderful past d-pawn
uh so instead after f5 we have e
captures on f6 alpha song by fabi queen
captures on f6 offering a queen trait
and queen e3 fabio of course declines
the queen trait and now bishop the g6
trying to get rid of this very strong
bishop uh look to d3 and even bishop to
f5 this is a very nice improvement by
shanklin because now if bishop captures
you're going to improve your pawn
structure you're going to get rid of
your isolated
e pawn
and it's just a very strong piece to
have here so how can fabi make progress
here he plays rook to c1 now if the
knight moves you will have pressure on
the c file
c6 now no longer is the c6 square needed
for for the light square bishop uh we
have rook to c2 as the bishop nicely
covers this diagonal we want to be able
to shift it
uh to a light square and now rook to d7
uh shanklin now also can bring this rook
into the game knight to e5 attacking the
rook and rook d6 knight c4 rook d7
knight to e5 and rook d6 shankland
agreeing to a repetition uh but fabi
declines this of course he knows if he
wins he's the u.s champion and he will
of course try to fight so here we have
rook b to d8
and now just f3 adding another defender
to the bishop here of course if black
captures we're going to improve our pawn
structure in the center uh but here
comes a really really awesome idea by
shankland and this game is just really
full of awesome ideas by both of them
and that's bishop captures pawn captures
and now
uh of course comes the move from the
thumbnail and that is queen captures on
e5 so shankling gives up the queen for a
rook and a minor piece uh and of course
fabi has to accept this so d captures on
e5 we have rook captures on e3
queen to a7 now going after some pawns
here as you really have nothing better
and now bishop to e1 there is no defense
against rook captures on g3 so here
queen captures on b7 there's really
nothing better and now rook captures on
g3
so you could bring your king to f1 but
this would be very dangerous for example
if king to f1 we can simply play rook to
f8 and now it's a problem if you play
this then we're going to play rook to g1
with check king e2 we're gonna play uh
rook to g2 with check and after uh the
king moves uh if you if you go for
uh this move then rook to f3 check and
then we just pick up the rook so nothing
really going on there so fabi tries king
the h2 uh he doesn't want to
go for the said line and now rook d to
d3
uh just uh doubling up here on the third
rank and how do you how do you continue
this with white well you could play
queen captures on c6 and say okay black
really has nothing here it's just you
know nothing
or what fobby played queen to c8 check
king to h7 and now queen captures on e6
now guarding against the rook the h3
check because of course black cannot
give up the two rooks for the queen now
he's just going to be left with a worse
end game playing a rook against the
bishop if any of you guys are interested
in seeing this uh this would be the
resulting end game of course white would
be completely winning now so instead
after a queen captures an e6 we have
rook to g6 attacking the queen queen to
f5 now uh you are ready to start pushing
that past e pawn and bishop the g3 check
now and again a very very dangerous
position uh for example if king h1 it's
very easy for black to get some sort of
a
drawing mechanism for example rook d1
check king g2 bishop captures an h4
opening up a discovery king h3 and now
you move the bishop bishop to e7 and
it's a really really ugly position for
white uh where black can just continue
checking from wherever uh so instead
fabio went for the king g2 right away uh
allowing the nasty discovery but there
is nothing nastier than bishop captures
on h4 so bishop captures king to f1 now
rook to e3 uh trying to checkmate fabi
would rook to e1 checkmate the bishop
covers f2 the rook covers g2 and g1
uh so fabi has to play rook to c1 there
is nothing uh better than this and now
shanklin plays c5 really uh preventing
that b4 from being played but also just
saying to fabi what do you play here how
do you improve your position there is
only one way for fabi to improve his
position and it's not an easy one to
spot so feel free to pause the video
here and try to find the only move that
allows fabi to play for the win while i
give you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
move uh because it's really the only
move in the position you can play uh and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show it's pawn to e6 that's the the
move fabi did not play this fight play
something else queen to f4 is also
interesting putting pressure on the
bishop and on the rook here uh but it's
not all that impressive because for
example if queen to f4 we can just play
rook to g3 and now if you capture here
we can play rook to g1 check and pick up
the rook so
now we've only uh traded a minor piece
for a rook not really something that
should be played however if you found
pawn to e6 this is extremely complicated
but it does wonders for white because
now if you look at it white is black is
sort of in in swank black has no good
move uh you can't really keep uh this
pressure with this
checkmating idea here you have to move
something the rook cannot move if the
king moves to the back rank uh then we
we pick up the rook if if you move
anything then there is no more checkmate
so what you could do here is play
something like rook to g3 trying to go
for this rook that you want captures but
then we simply play rook captures on c5
and now okay you have this forced line
rook to g5 attacking the queen going for
the rook so queen to f8 the guarding the
rook and now rook to g1 with check king
e2 but now you have all of these squares
to hide your king all the way on the
queen side and now if rook captures an
e6 we can simply play queen f4 we go
after the bishop let's say rook g2 check
king d3 we're gonna move the bishop
attack the rook here now queen to f5
check we force this rook back or force
the other rook to uh block block the
check so rook e to g6 and now rook to b5
guarding this pawn and it's a very very
nice position for white where black
really doesn't have many options so this
is one way to do it after e6 to just go
for this rook the g3 idea the other one
is uh just c4 uh it seems like uh also
also a move that you can play uh because
the pawn cannot be captured the problem
is now you have e7 extremely powerful
move and now after bishop captures on e7
we can simply play rook to c3 there is
no more checkmate because the bishop
left the coverage of the e1 square and
now you have to trade rooks there is no
square for this rook and once the rook
is traded off the board then it's much
much easier for white to avoid any
checkmating ideas from black and black
really doesn't have all that much to do
with bishop f6 we can play e5 with
bishop back to g5 we can play e6 we
don't really care bishop to h4 and now
we can simply play queen to d5 we're
going to pick up this pawn next and
uh it's going to be very enjoyable or if
or or if rook to g4 we can simply play
queen captures on a5 create another pass
pawn and white would be winning here so
this is uh
critical critical in the position here
after this uh c5 move uh e6 actually
puts white in in a really really
incredible position favi played rook to
d1 first and now it's it's a bit of a
different uh
position because now shanklin plays c4
and this c4 is such a powerful move
because you remember that we discussed
that uh the the white king after all of
that that we mentioned will be able to
go up the board and hide on the queen
side well this pawn really prevents that
because it covers the d3 square and
that's going to be a problem fabi pushes
e6 now
but now comes rook uh sorry rook to g3
and now comes rook to d7 uh putting more
pressure on on
black's position now comes rook the g1
with check king to e2 and now rook to g5
uh sorry rook to g5 attacking the queen
so the queen has to move and there are
many many ways for you to
uh do something with your queen the
problem is if you play something like
queen to f7 we have rook to g2 and we
already said that the king cannot hide
on the queen side the d3 square is now
covered by the pawn on c4 and after king
e3 we can simply play rook to f6 uh
attack the queen here and if the queen
moves then the problem is you have this
beautiful bishop to have to check king
e2 bishop to d4 check all of these
squares are now covered by the pawn and
the bishop you have to go back king to
e1 now rook the g1 with check king to e2
and now rook to f2 will be checkmate so
that's something that can happen if you
uh go over aggressively with a move like
queen f7 another thing you could do is
play something like rook captures on g7
because this rook is pinned king will
have to capture you're gonna deliver
check king h8 and now play e7 uh it
seems like you are completely winning
now but still rook to g2 king e3 and we
can just give up the bishop and after
queen captures this is again a a draw
nothing much for white to look forward
to here
so after rook the g5 fobby played
something different fabi played e7 he
decided to give back the queen and now
we have rook captures on f5 e captures
on f5 and now rook to g1 a very
important move uh to prevent fabi from
bringing a queen into the game because
if fabi does this rookie one check we're
gonna move the king and now rook just
picks up the queen and now black is
winning so instead after rook to g1 we
have f6 uh trying to get the bishop to
lose the control of the e1 square but of
course we have
rook to e1 check right away king the d2
and now rook to e6 uh so what can fabi
play here he pushes f7 it seems like
he's completely winning but bishop
captures an f7 uh on e7 guarding uh uh
the pawn from promoting to a queen on
the f8 square so rook captures on e7 and
now of course not captures in promotion
we just play rook to f6 and we prevented
the pawn from becoming a queen so now
it's a race king c3 king to g6 king
captures on c4 and now of course rook
captures on f7 and now the material is
uh uh actually uh
in uh shanklin's favor he is up upon so
what do you play here well fabio of
course knows that this is now a draw at
best for him so he trades with rook
capture skin captures and only now b4
and now the b4 had to be played
otherwise black is just winning and of
course uh you can't capture this if you
capture then a5 is winning for fabi the
king
can is not in time to reach the square
of the pawn so the pawn will promote
easily so after b4 we have king to e6
now comes b5 by fabi uh king to d6 and
now of course king to d4 we have h5 by
fabi now king to e4 and now g5
we have king to f5 and now h4 making
sure that if the king captures the pawn
promotes so here we have king to g4 by
fabi now comes king to c5 king to h3
king to d6 we have king to g for king to
c5 king to h3
and the king to d6 and he was in this
position on move 66 that fabi and sam
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here you can never
capture this pawn because this pawn
marches forward and you can never
capture this pawn because this pawn
marches forward of course this is a draw
incredible incredible game really
complicated and really uh
a fine showing by shankland
adjusting i'm going to give up the queen
i'm going to play uh really really
active chess because if i just defend if
i just wait for fabi to come at me i'm
ju i'm i'm going to lose i've seen fabi
done this a million times so he gets a
draw and this means now that uh the tie
breaks uh after 11 rounds of the usgs
championship will be again between
wesley so samuel savion and fabiano
corona which is happening today so we're
going to cover that as well and we'll
see
who will be the uh us chess champion uh
2021 but those are now rapid games so we
are done with classical chess so we'll
see what happens uh should be should be
very very enjoyable
uh so yeah that's the game i hope you
guys uh enjoyed it i would like to wish
a very happy birthday to zuzwang in the
noosh uh and i would like to thank
jonathan turak charles curran and david
farney for contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the usgs
championship the tie breaks until it
ends
thank you i will see you soon and have
an excellent rest of your day